[Musique]
yann à montplaisir vice président de
l'assemblée de martinique et chef de
file de babi yar chance c'est la
composante droite de cet ensemble
hétéroclite à la tête de la cité à
millam nous plaisir
bonjour bonjour que reste-t-il de nos
amours legrand semble époux bas payant
chance se conjugue désormais à l'est
parfait jusque on a ce à quoi on a
assisté à jeudi dernier et je regrette
évidemment qu'il y ait des dissensions
qu'il y ait des divergences de vues
qu'il y ait des débats ça me paraît
normal naturel de j'avais d'ailleurs
moi-même enclencher un débat le premier
pratiquement enclenché ce débat en 2017
c'est en septembre 2017
ça me paraît sain par contre je regrette
et je déplore qu'on puisse en arriver à
des divisions et surtout quand elles
sont affichées à l'hôtel niveau de
violence parce que c'était assez clash
un veau personnellement vous êtes fait
chahuter personnellement par belfort
birota et par le président de
l'assemblée claude lise qui vous a quand
même dire qu'il n'avait pas de leçon à
recevoir de vaud bref d'aller vous faire
cuire un oeuf
je pense que c'était ses excès de
langage relève de moments de tension qui
peut y avoir
nous avons une divergence fondamentale
claude lise et moi et donc je pense que
peut-être belfort birota était un peu en
service commandé dans cette affaire sur
la manière d'assurer je dirais la
sérénité des débats
il/elle raison d'être la chose au vote
des élus il a eu raison même si le vote
a été faussé par un mauvais des comptes
puisque on a la preuve par puisque tout
est filmé on a la preuve que le décompte
a été mal fait mais là n'est pas le
débat
la houle là où je ne suis pas d'accord
avec lui c'est sur le fait que gronde la
parole ou pas aux délégations qu'ils
demandent c'est fondamental pour moi
c'est un principe de démocratie vous
n'avez jamais vu à l'assemblée nationale
quelques puissent être les bonnes
raisons de ceux qui souhaitent
s'exprimer directement au travers de
l'assemblée
vous n'avez jamais vu cela oui mais les
extrémités parce que toutes les
solutions envisageons préalables n'ont
pas fonctionné alors je suis aussi et il
faut le dire très clairement pour que
healy et l'écouté et le dialogue
si le président de l'assemblée par
exemple avait souhaité rencontrer une
délégation il lui appartenait de se
faire remplacer quelques instants ce que
j'aurais fait d'ailleurs avec beaucoup
de beaucoup de plaisir et puis d'aller
écouter la délégation s'il souhaitait
qu'une délégation d'élus écoute un
certain nombre de personnes
ils pouvaient le faire s'il souhaitait
que les élus viennent écouter pour
quelque cause que ce soit je ne parle
pas de cette affaire précise et bien il
lui appartenait à mon sens deux invités
avant ou après un autre les psys yaka
fokon la réalité il ya non plus la
réalité c'était que les élus de
martinique ne prennent pas assez en
considération ils ne répondent pas
suffisamment ça c'est votre point de vue
ça c'est votre point de vue non moi je
suis sont des délégations et les
désespérés exaspéré témoin de vous vous
savez je comprends la désespérance j'ai
entendu moi je vois des gens je sais ce
que c'est que la souffrance de certaines
personnes et puis imaginer la souffrance
de ceux on va revenir sur le fond du
problème moi je suis sur la forme pour
l'instant sur la forme je l' ai toujours
dit chaque fois que claude lise a fait
cela chaque fois qu'il a interrompu la
séance pour recevoir une délégation
je lui dis que c'était dangereux c'est
une pression sur les élus c'est ensuite
l'utilisation des ddd médias qui sont
venus couvrir une séance plénière et
comment allons-nous réguler la chose
comment qui va dire demain que tel sujet
nécessite d'être entendue au sein de
l'assemblée qui va dire non ce n'est pas
bon c'est tout simplement ça n'existe
nulle réalité yan monplaisir que ça fait
deux ans et demi que le grand ensemble
est pour bat payant chance est au
pouvoir que ça fait deux ans et demi que
des discussions reviennent mais cela dix
ans non non non non non non sur ce plan
là les discussions reviennent et les
opinions sont toujours les mêmes chaque
fois que chaque fois que le président
lise a reçu une délégation sur la
pression qui est venu et
exigez demandé et c'est chaque fois je
suis sorti parce que je suis contre ça
parce que vous savez je me suis fait je
suis vice président de cette assemblée
je me suis fait invectiver par un
syndicaliste qui était assis à la place
du président de l'assemblée à la place
de claude lise avec la corde claude lise
en présence de claude lise et des autres
élus un élu imaginez la gravité de la
chose
un élu d'une assemblée qui a été conviée
convoquée par le président avec un ordre
du jour qui se fait invectiver
interpellé du haut de la tribune par un
citoyen quel qu'il soit fût-il
syndicaliste ça n'est pas admissible en
démocratie c'est ça que je veux faire
comprendre monsieur j'aurais fait à
comprendre ce que ça n'est pas possible
alors rien au plaisir parlant de la
démocratie belfort birota élus rdm
rappelle qu'il est eu des mots crade des
démocrates de bonnes moeurs il a précisé
que son mouvement du rdmc battu pour
l'expression de cette liberté qu'il
n'acceptera pas de voir tout cela
détruit et là on va le site et par un
autocrate par une négo crac par
quelqu'un qui prend tout seul les
décisions
je regrette ces excès de langage
ouais alfred marie jeanne a été
clairement visés par ces propos je crois
que oui je veux tout le monde tout le
monde au sein de la quick il vise tout
cela je trouve je trouve que c'est
regrettable
alfred marie-jeanne est un homme qui
n'est pas toujours facile dans dans les
changes parce que c'est un homme
autoritaire
la martinique a quand même besoin d'un
peu d'autorité il doit percer a pour
cela aujourd'hui c'est la bonne personne
pour 7 pour écouter personne n'est
parfait cerceau de café personne
personne non mais j'allais continuer mon
propos en vous disant que dans le même
temps c'est quelqu'un qui est capable
d'entendre c'est quelqu'un de très
pragmatique si vous lui exposer et que
vous argumentez il est capable de
comprendre vous caresser dans le sens du
poil
je caresse personnes dans le sens du
poil vous connaissez mes positions je
suis un citoyen au service de mon pays
je veux simplement être efficace
aujourd'hui il y à une manoeuvre
politique qui voudrait décomposer cette
majorité qui
kim n 9 qui manipulent a naturellement
pérenne quand vous avez une opposition
une majorité l'opposition et c'est
normal c'est la démocratie elle
l'opposition fait tout pour essayer de
faire en sorte que ça ne marche pas
revenons alfred marie-jeanne l'homme
fort de la 7e qui quand même aller subi
des attaques de toutes parts devant la
justice dans son parti dans sa coalition
dans son action prenait martiniquais au
sein de cette 7e qu'il dirige est ce que
alfred marie-jeanne c'est un soldat
qu'il faut sauver aujourd'hui selon vous
il ya de montplaisir est ce que marie
jeanne est un martyr que l'on doit
soumettre à tous à toutes les sévices et
la question c'est la question que vous
me posez pas puisque vous me direz ce
qu'il faut le sauver
moi je vous dis que les excès ne sont
pas bons et tout cet acharnement qu'il y
a contre cet homme qui assume avec la
volonté des martiniquais qui ont quand
même choisi cette majorité qui assume
les responsabilités lourdes qui sont
celles de gérer une collectivité comme
la com com la collectivité territoriale
première fois rassemblement des deux
conseil général fo a eu l'occasion de
lui dire elle fred barry gérer les fonds
d'investissement pour le développement
économique c'est pas assez
il faut pas je les dis publiquement il
faut pas croire non plus que la vie soit
un long fleuve tranquille entre alfred
marie-jeanne est moins bon le contrat
nous nous voyons comment le contrat de
gestion va continuer à vivre le contrat
de gestion continuera à ville tant que
je considérerai que l'intérêt de la
martinique et de faire en sorte que
cette majorité fonctionne parce que s'il
s'agit de créer une situation de chaos
pour permettre à tel ou tel de
manoeuvrer dans le chaos
ça ne servira pas la martinique et
l'image de tout cela auprès de la
population qu est-ce qu on aurait
mauvaise image
cette image cette image que je ne
souhaite pas donner à la martinique
cette image de kankan permanent de tu as
raison tu as tort de tu n'as rien fait
je fais tout tout ça n'est pas bon pour
le match mais tout cela quelques heures
de l'arrivée du président de la
république qui forcément comment de tout
ce qui se passe
il a dès lors j'ai retrouvé ma réunis à
matignon du monde mais
quand même de la crédibilité de notre
classe politique vise américain du
premier personnage de l'état qui se
rendra quelques heures oui vous avez des
dossiers à lui soumettre on a des
dossiers à lui soumettre
quand il arrivera ici il sera informé il
aura une note ou des notes qui sont
préparées par ses collaborateurs dont il
saura à peu près ce qui se passe et
c'est vrai que ça n'est pas très
glorieux
la vie politique martiniquaise en ce
moment qui est faite essentiellement de
kankan qui est faite aussi d'un refus
d'accepter le résultat des urnes
vous savez moi je regrette par exemple
que l'opposition ne participent pas ou
peu ou mal aux commissions au travail
des commissions ces menaces alliés
disent recevoir les documents trop
tardivement et ils disent recevoir non
pas des documents de travail mais tout
simplement des intitulés jean claude
duverger la signale encore lors de la
dernière butte à dire ça c'est normal ça
ce qui n'est pas normal c'est que il ne
participe pas aux travaux ils quand
l'église ça au lieu de travail si
lausanne et maintenant maintenant
maintenant et que maintenant vous même
vous ne pouvez pas croire ça monsieur
vous pouvez pas croire ça vous même et
puis vous savez très bien que quand on
veut travailler on peut travailler moi
je souhaite qu'on travaille
et puis s'il y a des des documents
envoyés trop tard et c'est bon demandent
la correction et tout ça doit se faire
je suis d'accord avec vous je vous en
fais le crédit mais on travaille
ensemble on on se parle on ne s'infecte
yves pas en permanente
aujourd'hui il ya un martinique bashing
c'est à dire il y à des responsables du
plus haut niveau
on va revenir je leur dis plus haut
niveau au rythme du plus haut niveau en
un an du plus haut niveau de lamartine
avec tout le monde et vous me permettez
vous me permettrez lors des travaux non
je vous explique que ça n'est pas bon
pour la martinique c'est pas bon de dire
rien ne va c'est pas bon de dénigrer
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui va pas alors
il y avait quand on demandait qu'est ce
qui va pas on vous disait tcsp il a
démarré donc c'est fini ça c'est
derrière
qu'est-ce qui va pas en martinique
aujourd'hui jamais jamais depuis 2014
on a importé autant de marchandises à la
martinique est ce que vous croyez que
c'est le signe d'un pays qui ne va pas
on va dépasser 3 millions de containers
3 millions de conteneurs c'est
ça s'est jamais atteint ce sont des
chiffres jamais atteints je dis pas que
ce soit bien je dis pas qu'ils aient pas
des malheureux je ne dis pas qu'il n'y
ait pas des gens qui est pas de travail
je dis simplement il faut pas
caricaturer
parce que vous vous cassez vous casser
le pays quand vous faites ça quand vous
dites rien ne va
quand vous dites ils ne font rien nous
avons nous avons trouvé une situation
difficile et nous reprocher ce matin de
rapporter des propos tenus par des élans
vous êtes là pour ça quand même
rapproché les propos des élus rapporté
les propos des élus rapporté et et
ramener les rogations des citoyens c'est
vous qui êtes au pouvoir
les mémoires et c'est pour ça que je
vous expliquais c'est pour ça que je
vous expliquer qu'il ne faut pas faire
de bashing
pourquoi la production de la banane est
remonté on va faire plus de 110 mille
tonnes cette année
on n'a jamais importé autant le bâtiment
repart
le tourisme s'est jamais aussi bien
portée alors je dis pas que tout va bien
je suis pas parfait c'est bien mais bon
je dis simplement arrêter de dire que
les choses ne vont pas merci yan
monplaisir vice président d'acidd
martinique bien c'est d'avoir été dans
son crédit